[موسيقى]
في هذه الايام انقلبت الشمس في حركتها من
الجنوب الى شمال وسنعيش خلال هذا الاسبوع
اطول ليالي واقصر نهر في السنه على
الاطلاق وفي نقطه الانقلاب ينفتح علينا من
الشتاء باب ويتزامل ذلك مع النجم الثالث
من نجوم المربعانيه المسمى بشوله والعامه
يقولون اذا طلعت شوله طال الليل
العوله
[موسيقى]
وفي نهايه هذا الاسبوع يبدا النهار ياخذ
حصته من الليل ويستمر في الاخ لمده ثلاثه
شهور تقريبا وحين ذاك يتساوى في طول الليل
مع النهار في شهر مارس المسمى بابا ذر اذا
طلع اباذار تساوي الليل مع النهار وطول
ساعات الليل على بلدان الخليج خلال هذه
الايام تتجاوز 13 ساعه تقريبا والشمس
غايبه على القطب الشمالي له ثلاثه شهور
ولن تشرق الا بعد ثلاثه شهور في الليل سته
شهور والنهار سته شهور والشمس الان في
الضيافه القطب الجنوبي لن يرحل الحزن منك
ما دمت
تحسم ضيافته
[موسيقى]